uh if the whole world moved to their
favorite vacation spots then the whole
world would live in hawaii and italy and
cleveland
it smells so good
cleveland
so how long do you see yourself living
in new york like forever at least i did
really
you want to end up like that
no i'm gonna be like her oh there is
nothing like new york in the spring
it's a lot more money
like get away with murdering my first
wife kind of dough
jack donaghy's a legend i've read his
book like 20 times jack wrote a book
yeah jack attack the art of aggression
in business
oh no
he got here before us
you're not supposed to let that happen
that's chapter two in the book
we fake your death in an apartment fire
i'll need three teeth from both of you
the other day i walked all the way to
maryland gorgeous that guy just pitched
me a cologne called [ __ ] i'm gonna tell
you what i told him not just anybody can
do this although it's a great name and
i'm probably gonna steal it don't mind
if i do
i mean i can teach you guys how to fake
take real drugs like a pro i used to do
it all the time when i was undercover
all you gotta do is close your nostril
when you go down watch this
oh nope i didn't do it that time i got a
full snout full
oh
pimento huh i thought you were just
gonna be looking through the files or
something man sorry brother tai chi
helps keep the demons at bay right
and
do you have to do it in your underwear i
can't take them off cause then you'd be
looking right at my penis and testicles
can't argue with that logic
okay give me your booze i am nourished
by your hatred don't talk to eddie treat
him like you would treat a person in
another country that you paid
25 000 to hunt what are you talking
about what am i talking about i'm
talking about the best vacation in my
life
get my crossbow crossbow
uh
yeah old school hit and play here we go
that's not that impressive i am so tired
of the rat race
fellas
you got to keep it down okay i got to
work in the morning mommy is looking
very strong tonight mr de barber come on
fine 20 across the board
i don't want you to go into a coma and i
don't want to stab you in the face with
a giant fork
what
well that's not you i've been
threatening a lot of people lately liz
i need the rules
the last time i drank i ended up doing a
man on the street commercial for tarzan
on ice
he was awful
i mean
he was playing out of skates
and a little monkey was funny
oh i see it again
yikes yeah and i didn't even see it love
for floyd and caitlyn yeah
you're right
oh god
ah false alarm saved it hi there hello
we need to talk we'll make it quick i
got to go pull the plug on my dad in 10
minutes
okay they got to knock that off i mean
what does weird energy even mean am i
right there are wind chimes where my
ding-dong should be
you can punch me kick me pull my hair i
am a-okay being stabbed biting and
scratching are on the table you can use
fire you know what shut up all right
janet this relationship has been the
best seven hours of my whole life um
excuse me pal take you out of my desk
[Music]
don't be a dumb dog squad meet detective
adrian pimento he's been deep undercover
for the last 12 years but he's just
resurfaced and he's rejoining the
nine-nine
that
is
awesome
thank you for meeting with me mr
feinstein please
call me dennis weinstein they claim that
smoking is bad for you
but is there any medical evidence to
back that up look at this glass oh my
god
sure you can slit his throat but then
what are you gonna do with all the blood
uh we just leave it in his body where
blood lives close the old nosteroni in
the oh boy i got more that time
i got blood spurt ooh no don't use that
one hey go ahead
[Applause]
i gotta go kill my dad let's go i have a
very funny story about keeping my eyes
moist
[Laughter]
nope still not getting our vibe man
really
snooze
you guys ever been fox hunting i have my
own foxes flown in from russia we drug
them pretty heavily so they can't get
very far in fact mostly they just flop
around on the ground makes it easier to
just walk up and bow
stupid foxes
it's deeply erotic you know what i just
realized i i forgot something at home
i'm just gonna
floyd i didn't see you there
wow
you look great
do i i'm pretty tired from playing as
hard as i work
hey i hope i don't sweat on you
you can sweat on me and on a personal
note sir in my mind the foo fighters
song best of you is about your
managerial skills
lemon i want to kiss your boyfriend on
the mouth she's alive like a deer she
runs and sniffs and jumps and stares
she's not like the badger with its
glasses and its rules about weekday sex
those are good rules people have work in
the morning
[Laughter]
who was that [ __ ] that answered your
phone eight months ago whoa
floyd
yes
he just gets me
oh i think you got a little something
right here other side yeah
up a little really
you got it oh that movie was a complete
waste of time i thought it was moving
my bowels
reverse reverse skip skip draw four
oh hell no would you like to pet a real
police horse chef boyardee was born here
you know
did i fall down while i was with you
because my lower back is killing me
i'm gonna cut right to the chase i don't
like charity not to brag but i almost
have a full-grown penis now okay who was
hunter's buddy hmm
oh i was
oh crap
oh dennis what a mess you have 30
seconds to get out of this facility
[Music]
okay uh how did you get in the apartment
oh it was easy i just seduced the old
lady upstairs came down the fire escape
jimmied the window open bing bang boom
i'm inside your living quarters totally
of course next time you could just give
me a call you know two ways to pop in on
a friend i didn't kill the old lady
upstairs if that's what you're worried
about this smells like somebody spilled
chinese food in a bird cage guys i'm
telling you the fake snorting can work
what
oh
[Music]
jason jason jason jason jason
jason jason jason jason jason jason
jason jason jason jason james jason
jason it's the only job i've ever had
except for back in groceries at the
supermarket at the corner of atlantic
and clinton
i guess i could go back to that again
paper or plastic yeah still got it we
need your help great who are we killing
i won't do kids that's a rule but that
rule is negotiable if the kid's a dick
can't even get a cup of coffee
he's my current cfo but i might fire him
and hire you
you got kids no that's good dum dum
eddie has two kids
fine single bag it it's your funeral you
dumb son of a [ __ ] get out of here
idiot you know if we pooled our
resources we could be done in two shakes
of a lamb's derrick i'm gonna turn that
place into an elbow art salon and make a
killing why trust none of these dildos
release the hounds what hounds the
hounds is an fda-rejected cologne i've
been working on that makes everything
smell like wet dog
after what i've seen
after what i've done
i don't know that i deserve to be happy
of course you do
huh
i never looked at it that way
wow
that changes everything but for now i
got a great job
kick-ass girlfriend i deserve an
apartment to match and i think this is
definitely it
i'll take this one too my son ahmed will
keep his motorcycles here
oh
thanks for coming
i don't know what girl you're talking
about liz i'm single i'm a lawyer i i
wear nice coats i'm the michael clayton
of cleveland oh you're already there the
other candidate is an outsider and we
like to promote from within
plus his name is alan garkle
you're never gonna lose a job to a guy
named gargoyle
did someone say my name
no you're not gonna beat that
[Music]
well played garcon
you